break down the east side west side [ __ ]
because back in the day
it would always feel like there was like
tension between the two sides from like
an outsider's perspective it feels like
nowadays it's very a lot of everyone's
kind of just moving in the same
direction it's everybody [ __ ]
everyone's [ __ ] yeah
that's just what it is [ __ ] got
cousins on the east side because on the
west side when you cross
that separate east and west
it was like a big thing because like you
feel me like
you know some some west side [ __ ] was
scared to go on the east side some i
wouldn't say scared but you know you got
comfort zones right so then with
i guess
it take like one or two people to do
something and be comfortable on the east
side or the eastside come on
our way it just means like us
like he could say the same statement and
say his east coast [ __ ] or a few he's
out and he's scared to go west they
ain't really scared it's
they don't [ __ ] the west side and then
west had now [ __ ] each other ugly i
ain't gonna read it ain't nothing over
there that part like
he's like
if you find something like say like if
you go like to like a suburb of detroit
like you got people like you got people
in like utica that ain't never been
detroit right but you would think like
it's a whole bunch of black people
that's that been detroit you would think
anybody around never been to detroit
before but you're running to a black
person that's from utica or something or
man or even like troy and they'd be like
i don't got no reason to go not even
first but like far out places like
muskegon and [ __ ]
yeah i got home he lives out in troy
there's radio out there but i don't
think he's ever ever been cause he don't
got no reason right right
when you when you think about detroit if
you're not from there you're gonna think
it's rugged everybody gonna tell you
it's violent which it is but it's
violent everywhere you just got to know
what you're doing and where you're going
that's kind of the main takeaway i
probably took because i was out there
for a week i was like you know i feel
like uh everywhere has got their issues
but like i [ __ ] loved it out there
it's fun everybody was super cool i mean
the food was great the people were chill
and i was like i like i i don't
understand the um
i mean i guess the best like he said is
violence [ __ ] happens everywhere
everywhere
it happens here people get robbed on
melrose here you know what i mean like
so i feel like um
it's dope too because i feel like right
now detroit's pretty much i feel like
it's like detroit and memphis you know
really got got the culture right now you
know yeah um how did you guys link up um
we got family mutual families people
were [ __ ] [ __ ] like
[Music]
it's like i grew up with his little
brother though like i grew up with his
little brother okay i'd have been
homeless and sleeping in the house with
his little brother like all type of [ __ ]
like this
this
i
like one of his closest friends i grew
up like he was like one of my older
brothers like wanted somebody else like
was around he looked out for me so it
was just like a whole bunch of [ __ ]
though like we always running to mutual
family members and friends and [ __ ] i'm
still running the same circle yeah i
didn't realize uh you and uh baldy james
were cousins until we were hanging out
in detroit and he was shooting dice in
the house we're at and i was like you
guys going to work together he's like
he's my cousin bojic
shout out to baldi james man big bap no
that's cuz for sure he
he's the first [ __ ]
from
like my knowledge as far as
doing something
that was indeed
with the music from he said you know i'm
saying which was when he was signing the
nas right he was on mass appeal early on
yep
that's like
he did that when
a lot of [ __ ] were super well
known now
didn't even have
three percent of a buzz or wasn't even
rapping per se you feel me so
yeah he a legend us and he's still doing
big [ __ ] being a part of his health you
know what i'm saying the nba leather
tour
all the [ __ ] he do with alchemists you
know what i'm saying that's bro